l'une des principales applications d'une
machine learning et l'analyse d'image et
ce n'est pas étonnant pour nous autres
humains aussi les images sont une source
d'information majeure
la vue est l'indécence est plus
important pour une corde primates
sauf que l'analyse d'image pose un
problème assez intimidant chaque image
correspond à une dawn est de très grande
taille comme vous le savez peut-être la
taille des images prises par vos
téléphones et de l'ordre du méga pixels
ce qui correspond à des millions de 0 et
de 1 pour un humain train que lire ces
données au rythme d'une donnée par
seconde prendrait des semaines
pire que cela en termes mathématiques
une image correspond à un objet dans un
espace de très grandes dimensions d'une
dimension 1 million typiquement or comme
on l'a vu avec lg fis
ces espaces de très grandes dimensions
sont extrêmement vaste et contre
intuitif pour bien analyser ces monstres
il va nous falloir réfléchir à comment
exploiter les nombreuses propriétés très
spécifique des images mais plutôt que
d'y aller à coude invariants
mathématiques il se trouve qu
historiquement les informaticiens en
général notamment à certains viennent
car en particulier se sont tournés vers
la biologie
en effet les biologistes ont découvert
que le cortex visuel de nombreuses
espèces animales et en particulier des
mammifères avait une structure
distinctive celui ci se décompose en
particulier en cinq régions successives
appelé très originalement v1 v2 v3 v4 et
white flight des cinq du coût de la même
manière le cun et ses collaborateurs ont
proposé d'effectuer une analyse d'image
qui passait par un certain nombre de
couches de neurones intuitivement chaque
couche correspond aux calculs de
représentation de plus en plus abstraite
du contenu de l'image
typiquement la couche observable mesure
uniquement la luminosité et la couleur
de pixels la couche qui suit va étudier
différentes sortes de corrélation entre
des pixels voisins puis la course
suivante peut être essayer de mettre à
bout ces corrélations pour identifier
des lignes directrices
puis la course suivante va regrouper ses
lignes directrices pour identifier des
structures puis on cherchera à
identifier des composants comme des yeux
ou des oreilles puis on combinera la
présence d'yeux et d'oreilles que pour
un ferrer les concepts plus abstraits
comme la présence ou l'absence de chat
le réseau de neurones calcule ainsi une
abstraction croissante des données qui
lui sont représentés ce qui lui permet
de calculer en bout de ligne une
présentation sémantique de l'image avec
toutes les applications dont on a déjà
parlé dans les vidéos 20 à 23 ok ça
c'est pour le principe général de
superposition de couches de réseaux de
neurones et ce n'est en fait pas du tout
spécifique aux réseaux de convulsions
l'idée importante des réseaux de
convolution c'est surtout que chaque
neurone de chaque couche intermédiaire
n'était exposée car un champ récepteur
particuliers ainsi que le fait que
l'analyse de ce champ récepteur est la
même que l'analyse qui effectue un autre
neurones de la même couche avec son
propre champ récepteur pour illustrer
cela prenons le cas d'un neurone de la
première couche après l'accouchement
serviable ce neurones va typiquement
analyser une toute petite région du
champ visuel
prenons le cas simpliste où cette région
ne contient que neuf pixels avec
différents niveaux de luminosité le
neurone va alors multiplier la
luminosité de chaque pixel par un poids
synaptique possiblement négatif et
calculer la somme des luminosités
pondérer et puis ensuite ce qui est
souvent face et de ne retenir que la
partie positive du résultat ce qui
correspond à la fonction d'activation
relu dont on a parlé dans l'épisode 41
lespwa synaptique forme alors une
matrice dit de convolution on parle
parfois aussi de filtres ou de carnelle
l'idée générale des réseaux de
convulsions c'est d'utiliser la même
matrice de convolution pour tous les
champs récepteur de l'image
autrement dit si je prends un autre
neurones de cette première couche il
sera exposé à une autre partie de
l'image mais sept autres neurones
effectuera en fait les mêmes calculs que
le premier neurones en particulier et
surtout il utilisera la même matrice de
convolution tout se passe exactement
comme si entre l'accouchée observable
première couche il y avait tout un tas
de synapses qui étaient exactement les
mêmes mais trans latter pour être
appliqué à d'autres régions de l'image
et d'autres neurones de la première
couche en particulier ses synapses ont
toujours le même poids synaptic dans le
langage d'une machine learning
on parle de partage des poids synaptique
ou juste weight schering et c'est une
excellente idée puisque ça permet de
réduire drastiquement le nombre de
paramètres de nos réseaux de neurones
autrement dit au lieu d'apprendre les
poids de toutes les synapses entre la
couche observables et la première couche
il suffit alors de n'apprendre que les
quelques paramètres de la matrice de
convolution ça fait beaucoup moins deux
paramètres
alors en fait ce n'est pas tout à fait
exact il faut imaginer que dans la
première couche pour un même show un
récepteur il existe en fait plusieurs
neurones différents qui vont analyser le
même choix recept
et chacun de ces neurones va utiliser
une matrice de convolution différentes
ainsi chaque chant récepteur sera
traduit par un certain nombre de nombre
qui résume le contenu de ce champ un
récepteur on dit que chaque chant
récepteur est résumée par un certain
nombre de canaux et ça c'est vrai pour
la première couche pour la seconde
couche et ainsi de suite
mais c'est aussi vrai pour la couche
observable oui parce que chaque pixel
d'une image ne correspond pas en fait à
un ce nombre il correspond en fait à 3
nombre pour chacune des couleurs
primaires rouge vert et bleu
donc si je résume pour la première
couche pour chaque matrice de
convolution et chaque chant récepteur on
trouve un neurone qui calcule la matrice
de convolution appliquée au chant
récepteur lui applique une
transformation non linéaire et pendant
l'apprentissage du réseau de neurones se
sont directement les matrices de
convolution que l'on cherchera à
améliorer et ce qui est vraiment cool ce
faisant c'est que notre réseau de
neurones va être parfaitement en accord
avec une symétrie très naturelle du
réseau appelé l'invariance par
translation
ainsi quand j'observe une cuillère si je
tourne la tête
la cuillère subi une translation dans
mon champ visuel il semblerait
souhaitable que mon cerveau analyse
cette cuillère de la même manière qu'il
analysait avant translation et bien en
utilisant les mêmes matrice de
convulsions pour tous les champs
réceptif c'est justement ce que garantit
automatiquement notre réseau de neurones
de convolution dit autrement les réseaux
de convolution ont une architecture pré
programmés pour l'invariance par
translation des images on y est presque
il reste tout de même un petit problème
en fait ce faisant on ne diminue
absolument pas la taille des données à
analyser
pierre si on a plus de 3 canaux dans la
première couche du réseau on en vient en
fait à augmenter la dimension des
données or on a justement dit que le
gros problème des données comme des
images c'était la malédiction de la
dimensionnalité qui fait que les
vecteurs de dimensions 1 million ou plus
sont en fait très difficile à analyser
c'est pour cela qu'on a ajouté
généralement ensuite une phase de
réduction de la dimensionnalité qui
revient résumé l'information de
plusieurs neurones voisins en une seule
information typiquement pour chaque
canal ou considère tous les neurones
associés à ce canal et dont les chants
réceptif sont inclus dans une certaine
région de lima
je calcule alors la valeur moyenne des
excitations de ses neurones
on parle alors d'extraction de la
moyenne ou aveugles pauline en anglais
mais alors je ne sais pas pourquoi mais
il se trouve qu'en pierrick mans il
semble que ça marche mieux si on utilise
l'extraction du maximum ou max pulling
qui consiste à ne retenir que la plus
grande excitation de l'ensemble des
neurones considéré quoi qu'il en soit ce
faisant on obtient une représentation
moins précises de l'image mais qui a
aussi le bon goût d'être deux dimensions
moindre d'une certaine manière
après pauline on a alors décrit
différentes petites sous région de
l'image à l'aide de résumer composé de
quelques canaux qu'est-ce qui vient
ensuite eh bien il s'agit tout bêtement
ensuite et de recommencer des opérations
similaires non pas à l'image initiale
mais à la première couche obtenu après
l'opération convolution pulling on
répète ainsi convulsions pulling puis à
nouveau convolution pulling puis à
nouveau convolution bowling et ainsi de
suite
généralement en bout de ligne on obtient
un vecteur de bien plus petite dimension
et qui a une bonne représentation
abstraite des contenus de différentes
régions de l'image et on peut alors
mieux décortiquer ce vecteur avec un
réseau de neurones fit for world classic
ou même avec un réseau de neurones
récurrents typiquement si on veut faire
de l'analyse de vidéos enfin dernière
chose à dire étrangement les réseaux de
convolution ont des applications bien au
delà de l'analyse d'image de façon
étrange ils ont trouvé des applications
dans la compréhension de textes en
médecine et également pour le jeu de go
en fait c'est de façon générale les
réseaux de convolution semble utile dès
qu'il semble y avoir ne serait ce qu'une
partiel corrélation local plutôt que
global et une relative invariance
spatiale ou temporel mais une fois
j'avais déjà fait des liens entre les
réseaux de neurones récurrents et des
raisonnements cognitif qu'on pourrait
avoir au niveau du cerveau biologique
notamment et bozon de geek demande si ce
genre de recherche en intelligence
artificielle et en réseaux de neurones
artificiels en particulier pourrait
donner plus d'une série de plus
d'informations sur la nature d'une
pensée humaine qu'elle est comme ça
alors là je sens qu'il ya quelque
biologiste qui sont en train de rebondir
dès à dire mais c'est impossible
les réseaux non artificielle n'ont rien
à voir avec les réseaux de neurones
belgique en particulier neurones
artificiels n'ont rien à voir avec
neurologique
en effet il ya un peu un gap entre les
deux cependant si on croit notamment à
la tête de turc featuring dont elle est
parlée dans l'épisode 4 de cette série
on a tenté de penser que le cerveau
humain n'est rien d'autre qu'une machine
à calculer et que tout ce qui se passe
dans le cerveau n'est que le résultat
d'un très grand nombre d'opérations et
il y a un problème de son père rivers
engine ring à ces pratiques qu'elle est
de savoir
étant donné un truc qui marche comment
est-ce qu'on peut inférer son
fonctionnement interne pour reconstituer
son fonctionnement est finalement essayé
de construire nous mêmes un truc qui
résonne aussi bien que le cerveau humain
va forcément nous amener à des questions
qui se pose également pour le cerveau
humain et du coup forcément on va
apprendre un peu plus sur n'ont pas
nécessairement ce qu'est exactement le
cerveau humain mais au moins des
fonctionnements un peu macroscopique du
cerveau à lui un peu l'idée du
fonctionnement global du cerveau et
peut-être même de façon plus générale m
manière assez globale de réfléchir et en
fait dans mon livre c'est une
perspective encore un peu différente que
j'ai prise puisque je me suis demandée
sur la forme du savoir quelle était la
meilleure façon de savoir et si on en
croit le bail à nice mme la meilleure
façon de savoir c'est d'appliquer la
formule deux pays
le problème de la formule d'obèses est
très au courant c'est le fait que cette
formule de belz demande des calculs qui
sont irréalistes en pratique et du coup
pour pouvoir bien réfléchir on est
obligé de se contenter d'approximations
de la formule de beille du coup pouvoir
bayésiens savoir comment bien réfléchir
et en particulier vu que le cerveau
humain quand même réfléchir bien mieux
que des algorithmes capables d'écrire
quand même à le penser c'est que d'une
certaine manière le cerveau humain
arrive à calculer de meilleure
approximation de la forme de pays ce que
ce dont on est capable de faire
nous avec nos algorithmes que l'on écrit
du coup vous envie de dire que forcément
si on réfléchit mieux à comme à ce que
le cerveau parvient à faire les calculs
qu'il fait et a abouti en conclusion
qu'il fallait surtout quand ces
conclusions semblent en fait très très
bonne et qu'on n'arrive pas à
l'expliquer c'est une façon de nous
pousser dans leurs retranchements et
d'essayer de faire mieux en intelligence
artificielle et al'inverse qu'on
intelligence artificielle on trouve des
méthodes qui fonctionne tout à coup
beaucoup mieux que les méthodes
précédentes qu'on avait inventé en
influence artificielle ça laisse parfois
même à penser que ce genre de méthode
convient de découvrir révèle quelque
chose ça c'est fondamental sur quelles
sont les meilleures façons
d'approximations formule de bèze
de façon pragmatique et si tel est le
cas on peut vraiment s'attendre au fait
que le cerveau humain applique ce genre
de calcul en savoir plus sur ces
merveilleuses relations entre les
neurosciences d'un côté et les
raisonnements plus algorithmique de
l'autre côté je recommande très très
très vivement les cours de stanislas de
haine au collège de france je crois que
c'est les années 2012 à 2014 si vous
vous trompez pas 2012 1013 du xiii et
louis xiv ou sané 6 2 n a donné des
cours intitulé le cerveau statisticiens
et le bébé statisticiens qui sont
vraiment des découvertes assez
fantastique sur des modèles très utile
pour point c'est la condition humaine et
j'espère que âgées mais cette vidéo la
pression on va continuer notre
exploration des différentes
architectures utile des réseaux de
neurones qui sont souvent également
inspiré des cerveaux humains puisque on
parlera des réseaux très profond
notamment des réseaux résiduelles si
vous aimez cet épisode spécial de l'ikea
le portail de partage et pour ça il ya
donné pour l'épisode leur seul titre
ford et j'espère que vous serez la
prochaine commission reebok pour au pied
qui pourrait la fin des années 80 quand
j'étais malade dans new jersey donc
laboratoire laitiers ainsi la compagnie
téléphone américaine j'ai en fait
travailler sur des premiers réseaux
collectifs qui était d un petit peu
inspirée du
nous connaîtrons de fukushima mais
utilisant ses ago rides des centres de
gradient d'avoir supervisé de rétro
propagation